welcome back to new rock stars this is a
breakdown to the boys season two episode
six
the bloody doors off i'm eric boss this
is the boys underground the boys after
show that
still isn't totally sure if stormfront
is a nazi they're
they're really slow playing this one
don't you think
i'm just waiting for definitive proof i
mean
yeah yeah she has the hidden nazi box
full of hitler youth knives but like
i don't know they could they could
underline it a bit more i mean
as of now it still seems like we could
just be those typical
hollywood types that are reading into
things making everything racist when it
ain't even though this is our natural
florida accent
right that's right yeah most of our
blood is swamp water
yeah swamp water and gatorade it's the
same thing
as you can tell with me to join some
thoughts on bot
is the lamp lighter to my frenchie i i
guess that
comparison works off-screen producer
zach huddleston welcome to the show
hello eric there's some blood on these
hands in on this zippo
hopefully that blood isn't tommy and
marina don't worry tommy marina will be
back soon both of them
just had uh other conflicts this week
but they'll be back on the show soon
yes so this was a pretty interesting
episode a lot of things came together
zach why don't you summarize it for us
absolutely eric so
this was a lot of action this episode so
the boys headed down to the sage grove
facility had kind of been teased on
stormfront's emails
in the previous episode there they
learned from lamplighter
past member of the seven whom starlight
replaced that vaude is testing a more
stable version of compound v
on human adult subjects including
the body imploder cindy who escapes
lamplighter is a much more sympathetic
empathetic version of the character than
the one we got in the comics
and he feels guilt over accidentally
killing colonel mallory's grandkids
before the series started frenchie
shares that guilt because he lost his
hail on lamplighter trying to save his
attic boyfriend
jay and we learned frenchie's real name
eric serge can come
right now i just thought it was frenchy
what's wrong with frenchie as a name i
mean we call you american e
all the time yeah all that i am pretty
american-y yeah
so back at the sage grove not to be
confused with the surge grove
a breakout among the kind of inmate
patients
causes huey to get gravely injured it
gets like impaled by a big old chunk of
metal yeah you know when characters flip
in cars like an inception
that's not a safe thing i guess
sometimes a shrapnel shard will go right
into your gut
it's a good reminder to me to take out
all those loose pieces of metal
out of my car i'm leaving mine in
okay fair enough
to try to save him uh starlight kills a
driver
but she feels no guilt over it which is
kind of strangely creates a bond
between her and billy butcher because
they're both cold-blooded in their
pursuits
mother's milk is almost strangled by the
world's longest
love sausage fetish i didn't realize i
had
until i witnessed it talk about mr
fantastic huh
yeah it speaks for all of us uncut uncut
which is interesting how do you
circumcise
the snake that big where to begin that's
like a four-foot skin
okay um kind of at the one of the
climaxes of the episode
colonel mallory is convinced to spare
lamplighter
so that he can help the team he's kind
of joining up with the boys in some way
uh meanwhile in some subplots uh the
deep uses his fish friends to recover
a video recording from flight 37 that
may
plans to use to blackmail homelander but
of course her girlfriend
elena sees the video and doesn't like it
the deep also
tries to recruit a train into the church
of the collective in a really fun scene
and homelander and stormfront's violent
passion
deepens in uh some real gross kinky ways
stormfront reveals to him
her nazi origins what we were talking
about and well we didn't yet know
that she was the wife of frederick
vaught she's a legit 100 years old
and she plans to use homelander to lead
a neo-nazi
army in a race war and of course
homelander the egotist and fascist that
he is
is all about it yeah that's uh it was an
interesting but not all that surprising
union between the two of them because
homelanders been dropping some like
veiled or not so veiled kind of superior
pseudo-racist stuff from the beginning
so yeah they've done a really good job
bringing these two
who started as rivals to see their
mutual agreement on a lot of issues and
now of course they're they're one of the
same and i am terrified
yes i and i i for one was surprised by
the
uh mrs vaught revelation eric did you
see that coming
no no i i had some theories that maybe
uh she could have been related to him
maybe she could have been him
herself you know and kind of a
disembodied brain
sort of deal but uh yeah the fact that
they'd be married
is an interesting thing because it
brings up the question of like well then
where is he
or what happened to him yes yeah he was
willing to experiment on his wife do we
think he was probably also willing to
experiment on himself
yeah yeah there's uh there's a lot of
interesting questions to come out of
out of this big reveal and in a very
violent fun sequence it reminded me a
lot of cabin in the woods
where they they look on all the
different security screens to see the
melee that's going on
and you just hear screams going on who
knows how many people died and
what horrible ways they died and i love
the reveal of the long
tentacle um you know dick because i'm
thinking
like i'm thinking missed i'm thinking
toad from x-men tongue that's dragging
someone of their doom but
nah it's dick of course on a show like
the boys it's gonna be a dong
yeah well uh let's break down the
top 10 big easter eggs and visual
details that you might have missed from
this episode because there's a lot of
cool stuff
that that's kind of hard to notice at
the beginning let's start with the
episode title it's called the bloody
doors off which yeah is a reference to a
boy's comic title all the episodes of
the series are referenced to boys comic
issues
but the deeper origin of this phrase is
michael kind's
famous line in the italian job you're
only supposed to blow the bloody doors
off yeah
that film moment zach to me is like the
boys in
a bloody diabolical nutshell because
it's like the encapsulation of the
overkill
that rings especially true for this
episode in which quote unquote good guys
like starlight frenchy billy butcher
they all kill
far more heartlessly than usual it's
really a mixed bag of morality and i
think it's gonna be very important to
how we see the boys going forward
and then yeah of course the episode
opens and closes with references to the
sitcom
golden girls the golden girls those
saucy ladies
they made their own family you are my
blanche
you are my dorothy
so you're betty white oh what else
question
of course i'm betty white and yeah zack
i'm sure you caught that golden girls
theme playing at the end of the episode
i think it's worth noting that this is
the second time the boys have compared
themselves to famous girl groups of
course after the spice girls
you put them together
elegant sparse girls how do you know so
much about the spice girls
which you know it's kind of like a
little ironic in joke by the show that
despite their masculine name they most
relate to the qualities of things like
compassion
support sisterhood beautifully that's
kind of what sets them apart a little
from the seven
i'm i'm just disappointed that the
writers missed an opportunity to say
something along the lines of golden
girls get it done
yeah oh that's gotta oh please please
bring that back
um now speaking of like girls get it
done with that superhero
moment it's worth noting that golden
girls is tied to joss whedon and his
family's history because his father
tom whedon was a big tv screenwriter as
well he wrote on golden girls
which did launch nepotistically joss
whedon's career
as a sitcom writer on shows like
roseanne that was before
joss would go on to work on things like
buffy the vampire slayer and angel
and of course superhero movies that the
boys comment on citing joss whedon
by name last episode so it all comes
full circle there now we didn't get any
billy joel music clues this episode
which is a bummer but
he does wear a shirt depicting billy
joel's the stranger
and i love how this episode opens with
huey getting sprayed
with his ex-girlfriend's blood in the
face when they remove her tracking chip
and that shirt later gets soaked in
blood it's just a little reminder that
that blood that he got coated in while
he was debating
billy joel music with robin in that
opening scene it's kind of blood
that he'll never be able to escape on
this show love and violence
forever linked for huey and yeah in that
scene it's not really miserable french
he wears goggles just like he's depicted
in the comics hey side note i don't
really care about that
you know adaptation details are not
easter eggs like oh look harry potter
has borat scar just like he does in the
books like
if that's going to be your kind of
comment like oh it's just like this in
comics
that's not a detail don't comment okay
fourth detail home later and stormfront
banging that alley
uh he's in the blood of the thief whose
skull gets crushed
and there is some fun graffiti if you
look around there's the uh homelander
saving america posters they're defaced
with his eyes ext out maybe a reflection
of his like blindness
to stormfront's nazi agenda there's
another tag that reads
r.i.p spidey which i don't know if
that's like a spider-man thing
obviously spider-man doesn't exist in
this universe but i just thought it was
a fun little thing to see
but the cool detail here notice the line
sometimes it feels like
like the justice system just doesn't
work anymore
everyone always recording on their phone
all the time
yeah stormfront is the one who's always
recording on her phone
something that pissed off homelander
last episode when he was caught on
someone's phone
and yeah it's a recording of homelander
and made from flight 37 that's gonna be
reappearing late in this episode but my
favorite part of this
i'm pretty sure that is a cctv camera
recording them
in this exact moment in the alley the
skull crush is visible by the angle but
stormfront smartly rubs homelander
out of sight from the camera his back is
turned to the camera
and then when they gets around the
corner away from the camera
interesting i'm sure she is aware of all
recording devices in the vicinity all
right fit detail
mallory talks about frenchie's history
with uh some of the other soups
and cold snap two months ago malchemical
a month before that you don't know about
those either yeah cold snap
uh malchemical those are soups from the
comics actually you can see a cold snap
poster
showing up in frenchie's apartment but
mallory mentions a darker entity in this
world
adx florence there's a super max in
colorado they've got the unabomber head
of the aryan brotherhood all the greats
that aryan brotherhood mention a little
reminder that neo-nazism
is sadly alive and well in the united
states
something that uh definitely comes back
at the end of this episode it makes
stormfront's nazi reveal
even more not that shocking all right
next detail in the sage grove medical
center
are some more familiar soups there's
tiny hero whom we saw in the soup sex
club
in the first episode of the series the
acid spewer who has that horrible death
uh
is probably based on discharge from the
group g whiz in the comics
and of course there's love sausage he's
based on the russian suit from the
comics
and yeah it seems like he dies this
episode which is a bummer because he has
a really fun arc in the comics but in
the comics his dick doesn't stretch out
like that
but for comics readers it might have
felt a little ironic to see
mm as the one who gets strangled with it
minor spoiler warning for the comics
here
uh so if you haven't read the comics
you're gonna be bummed by learning
something skip ahead a little bit
but in the comics mother's milk gets his
name from the fact that he needs his
mother's breast milk to survive
going forward and his mom is this like
tragically disgusting figure who lives
in his basement
and grows into this gross blob with her
breasts
stretching out in a similar tentacle way
to the way this dick does that strangles
mother's milk so i don't know if it was
intentional that it connected that way
but i did think for a second i'm like
wait is his mom
being kept in this facility and that's
what's strangling him right now
but no that wasn't there there are some
questions right like we don't know what
uh his father the the litigious
character that's been mentioned at
before
why he was suing uh vots so aggressively
right or how that totally resolved so
interesting yeah for sure for sure
there's more to learn there for sure
all right let's talk about lamplighter
sean ashmore who i gotta say it again i
love the fact that he's playing the
zippo
pyrokinesis guy which is essentially
what his rival in the x-men movies was
he was ice man he was a cold snap of
that world whereas uh
yeah he has a zippo now it's fun fun
little thing now in the past we learned
that lamplighter was
recruited to work for the boys he was
blackmailed with some mystery photos now
the angle
blocks mallory's tablet but there are a
few clues that tell us
what uh what was on that there was that
red carpet for his light in the shadow
journey in a night premiere where he
comes off as a ladies man with a pretty
young
date i'll say sean ashmore isn't that
old but the date is just significantly
younger and then when they make fun of
his look they say that he looks like a
baton twirling majorette
which stings him personally in an
interesting way
as if to say you're why are you bringing
up like a young cheerleader
right now and then it's a zippo lighter
it says titty committee
uh in an interview sean ashmore said
that his first question when he read for
this part was
what what are they using on him what's
his dark secret
well apparently that lighter connects to
some sexual relationship that he had
with underage girls
he's a predator and i'm thinking maybe
it was connected to high school
cheerleaders based off of that majorette
comment
those photos that mallory had were of
some past
sexual encounter he had with someone
that was illegal and that's why he had
to
step down from the seven interesting i i
like your inferences there
eric okay really cool detail here
outside huey's hospital room there's a
poster with maeve encouraging people to
donate blood which
is now pretty ironic with maeve as an
lgbt person because the fda
until recently had issued guidelines
prohibiting sexually active gay men from
donating blood
due to some lingering fears some
misunderstandings about
the hiv epidemic starting the 80s now
those restrictions have recently been
relaxed under covid but it's just
interesting that the lgbt member of the
seven
is now associated with this poster
saying hey donate blood
except if you're this type of person no
that poster might have been hanging on
that particular hospital wall for like
five years
she's only been noted recently yeah
absolutely absolutely we're not saying
it's a new post to print it it's just
saying that now
poor mate probably has to walk around
and see the way she's been depicted in
the past and be like
oh i would not make a poster like this
now and also makes you think about this
whole time she's been living with this
this you know double standard of the way
she's being presented versus the way she
knows she is on the inside and
it just it sucks that it's just a little
reminder that she's been misrepresented
this way i thought it was interesting
how
the flight 37 recording ended with
i love you tell the boys i love them
this poor poor guy sending a message of
love to his sons but also he says the
boys it's just
i don't know maybe a little thing that's
showing that like you know the necessary
evil of the boys
is gonna be the thing that brings
homelander to justice i think ultimately
also what an endorsement for gopro
cameras
that it was able to survive a plane
crash and at the bottom of the ocean
those things are tough they couldn't
find the black box
but they could find it well that's the
old joke of if i think it's a seinfeld
joke if the black box always survives
the plane crash make the whole plane out
of a black box
we should make a whole plane out of a
gopro
and uh lastly the thing we're gonna talk
about to know and surprise stormfront
confirming her
nazi heritage she's got that good old
nazi box
which i don't know i have some older
relatives who were american gis during
world war ii
and then they did like tear nazi patches
off of like uh
german soldiers as like trophies but
like you know i think some people find
that it's like an american beauty
they're like why do you have this stuff
it's like oh no we we fought on the
right side of history and
we want to remember you know that that
good fight
but um but some people collect too much
of this stuff
and then you start asking questions as
we see
with storm front in that box if you were
to look closely yeah she's got her
liberty costume
she's also got a german verchmacht hat
you know and she's got that knife and
it's a hitler youth knife
it's a field knife that a lot of german
soldiers had it's got that symbol
that matches the s of the shootstop volt
that's the ss
uh and her lightning earrings that we've
been seeing her wearing this whole time
do match that hard angle s shape now
ayakash did such a good job with this
with that monologue i hated hearing it
but the way she delivers it is so
creepily convincing um of like that she
truly believes this stuff
and uh there was that accent leak that
she puts into her pronunciation of
proper announce like
i was born in 1919
in berlin heinrich himmler and that's
gobbles
yeah despite her evolving american
accent over the decades it it makes
sense that she would be unable to shake
that pride and endearment of those parts
of german history
just a little creepy thing she did that
i thought was great and i just got to
say
zack and i know you agree with me on
this i know it seems like everything
these days is being framed as like they
old symbols for neo-nazis like you can't
make certain hand gestures anymore you
can't have tiki torches anymore but
folks that is the scary truth of this
country
that u.s flag draped homelander
immediately making out with stormfront
after learning her nazi truth
is uh pretty on point commentary about
how
american brand fascism comes from the
same dark place
that german fascism did just because we
fought a war against them
i think a lot of americans have
forgotten the history of that
and our history is scarily repeating
itself yes
in that i think the scariest part about
that ideology
is how seductive it can be to certain
people
right like if it were universally
abhorrent it would go away and we'd
never see it again
right but because it keeps sucking in
different people especially i think
somebody like homelander
who is very like almost onanistic right
we saw in that
the weird sex scene with um doppelganger
right like
he loves more than anything homelander
right and so certainly an ideology
that's gonna raise him up to be like an
iconic figure
he's all about it oh yeah i'm your i'm
your blond-haired blue-eyed superman
sure let's do it well the good news is
despite this whole idea of overkill from
the bloody doors off title making us
worry about the comparable
moral decline between the seven and the
boys the
pure golden girls thank you for being a
friend
is the antidote to that evil zack notice
how the way cindy gets away in the final
shot
she does not kill that driver the way
starlight and butcher killed their
driver when they were trying to
hitchhike
she gets in the passenger seat she is
victorious where
our boys have not learned to be a good
friend yet
interesting now on the question of cindy
zach i'm curious about you we saw cindy
basically blowing up and popping bodies
is this confirmation that cindy was the
one who killed rayner
in episode one well that's a good
question it's certainly kind of
inferring that though we also saw in
this
exact episode there were multiple supes
with telekinetic powers right there was
a guy that lamplighter incinerated
could move like a little ball in the air
so maybe he wasn't as powerful or
advanced as cindy but
who knows how many soups can pop heads
and also that would mean that somehow
cindy who does not like being locked up
in sage grove
was able to be transported to a third
location
kill rainer and then be brought back
maybe maybe she was drugged or something
like that
but then yeah they didn't mention there
was like a propofol drug that she was
given but if she was drugged like that
would she be able to use her powers to
blow up someone's head i don't know
yeah i also think it's strange again
we'll have to figure out why was raynor
killed in that moment but not
frenchie and mother's milk right who are
also there yeah
right why not kill everybody that was
there at the time yeah
so it's it's not a a closed case right
now i
i think it could be cindy but i it it's
still kind of an open question
we have some more open questions that
we're going to be discussing in just a
second but first we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this
episode our friends at the true crime
reporter podcast so do you want to go
into a journey of darkness into the mind
of the worst sadistic serial killer
in texas history well the new true crime
reporter podcast reveals
how a corrupt parole system released
alan mcduff
and how just one day after mcduff walked
out of prison women's bodies started
turning up dead across central texas
peabody award-winning investigative
reporter robert riggs the host the
creator of the true crime reporter
podcast reveals
the inside story of the serial killer
described as the devil himself
and the only convicted killer to ever
receive three death sentences in texas
holy crap the 30-year veteran journalist
pulls out his reporters notebooks and
law enforcement case files in this 15
episode series premiering on september
28th
the true crime reporter is a
co-production with podcast ad reps and
is their first par original podcast it's
also currently in development as a tv
series
free to kill so this is an amazing story
you're gonna want to check it out don't
miss this blood chilling series
subscribe to true crime reporter
on your favorite podcast app okay let's
move on to some deeper questions we had
coming out of this episode
zach i want to know from you now that we
know that stormfront is a straight-up
nazi
trying to restart a race war how does
stan edgar fit into that plan
like is he aware of it because he is a
person of color does he fit into this
it's a great question right and and we
know that like stan edgar
from what we've seen of him and we
haven't seen a whole lot
right like he is a pro guy right he
worships at the altar of
and doing big business and increasing
profits in corporate power
either a he's seen that he can ride the
wave
of kind of nazi-ish fascism
to more corporate power or he doesn't
see that part of it
and stormfront has kind of held the race
war
aspect of it away from him and just
selling him on increased power more
soups
run the world kind of stuff yeah now
this is kind of a stretch theory but do
you think it's possible that
i mean we've never seen stormfront and
stan edgar in the same place at the same
time i think but they are connected
is it possible that stan edgar could
have the mind or the soul of frederick
vaught
oh wouldn't that be great or we also
know shape shifting is a possibility in
this world right like he could have
shape-shifted into stan edgar or yeah a
weird kind of brain transplanty
uh yeah very modaki uh kind of situation
okay and uh eric on to our weekly black
noir watch
uh there were just a few mentions of
black noir he wasn't heavily featured in
this episode
uh homelander talked about going off to
run lines with black noir
on the set which is so funny because he
doesn't talk
but in their tv interview when he and
stormfront were sitting down for a tv
interview
they said some stuff about him black
noir is definitely
the biggest ego such a team under that
helmet
so what do you think this means about
black noir were they just kind of
cracking jokes or does that hint it like
a little bit of a personality i think i
think it does
i think they were cracking jokes but
they have been very careful to mention
or show black noir
at least once every episode which is why
we do the black noir watch
i think it's interesting that they say
how does it fit under the helmet her
line was kind of obscured
by the people talking in that scene i
don't know i think at the end of the
season we may look back at this moment
be like ha ha
they did mention like what it's going to
look like when you lift that helmet
off so i think it's going to be just a
little moment saying like
keep an eye on this character keep an
eye on the fact that there's going to be
a surprise reveal when we lift that
helmet yeah it's it's chekov's face at
this point
right really when that comes off it's
going to be a face we recognize or that
means something to us
right yeah okay next
next kind of lingering question here
eric what does it say about starlight
that she got into being a soup
to save lives but now she feels almost
no remorse
for killing that that driver on the
roadside
yeah right isn't that interesting that
she was just like it's just another
person in our way
you know and she's even kind of
reflecting on that and that's kind of
what brings her
and billy butcher together as they both
look on the pathetic huey
as justice like this puppy who's always
there for us it is super interesting
that she looks over the child seat it is
just that
moment but it's the same thing that made
huey
really nervous back last season when he
found out translucent had kids
and he didn't want to kill him but he
did it anyway so it's just like
yeah it's it's just kind of they go
through these same beats of like just
because someone's a parent
doesn't mean that i'm going to lose a
ton of sleep
over killing them but i i would say
killing translucent is something that
still haunts huey
more than it appears to haunt starlight
over killing this guy yeah
but i want to know from you uh let's
talk about maeve now that elena knows
what happened on flight 37
uh do you think it's gonna create some
tension between the two of them
is it even gonna work on homelander to
be blackmailed yeah it does seem like
she's dug herself in deep right like
that's
the the growing tension of this season
and now we're six episodes into an eight
episode season right so we're getting
to the point where like all the stakes
are getting raised
everybody's in trouble and certainly her
trouble is she feels like her only way
of getting out underneath the thumb
of homelander is to use this blackmail
tape but we know
like he doesn't respond really well to
any kind of threat
no no oh yeah yeah so um
who who knows it does seem like if she
were just gonna release it to the press
maybe she would have already done that
i hope that it doesn't lead to a
situation where maeve has to like kill
elena or something like that
um that would be really heartbreaking
that just because homelander found out
of it because it seems like that's where
it's headed right the moment homeland
found out about elena and it's gonna
like i don't feel great about elena's
survival
no or maves for that matter right
anybody that's going into direct
conflict with homelander you have to
worry about their safety
yeah yeah it's kind of like you know we
keep comparing it to like game of
thrones
when you have these shows where there's
a lot of warring parties kind of these
moral figures that are in the center of
the different boring parties who really
worry about their survival into the next
season because like i don't i don't see
a place for you in this world
all right uh let's talk about the fresca
so
uh the deep recruits a train with a
fresca holds it out the same way eagle
the archer randomly gave it to him
you know it's super weird obviously
there are connections to the church of
scientology we see aleister aldana
uh he's head of the church of the
collective he's got a portrait that's
framed
very david miscavige with uh another
portrait that seems to be there el ron
hubbard the mansion
clearly based on the scientology
hollywood celebrity center castle that
you and i have seen many times when
we're waiting in line at ucb and look up
and be like what is going on in there i
hear screaming
and uh yeah they mentioned a documentary
clearly based on the hbo documentary
going clear
but weirdly they're all drinking fresca
at that table in nice goblets
what's going on with the bresca well and
i've both
had and seen a lot of different
explanations for the fresco
one it's just funny because nobody
drinks fresca right
all the cool kids have moved on to topo
chico or
uh other sparkling waters lacroix
right we're we're still rocking the
sprites and 7-ups right
who's drinking fresca and so it's it's
it's
funnily specific in that way then also
like you just mentioned like
it's a clear soda the going clear
if if like church of the collective is a
little bit aligned with like sober
sobriety kind of 12-step ethos
right it's something you can offer
people that's not wine or alcohol
um there's a little bit of that like um
i know like some people when they've
gone sober like they just eat candy
constantly or like
mainline cold brew coffee or whatever
right it's like
maybe there's a little bit of that um or
i've also
seen the theory that all fresca is
drugged to make people more susceptible
to uh
being recruited into this strange church
which i love the idea that like
at the source all fresco is drugged
these aren't special
frescas the entire product line
has sedatives in it but i'll say it
would be very creepy because it is a
can of fresca it's not like a you know
certain kind like cartons of something
that you can clearly just like get
uh because we found out with like the
russians you know they can they can get
a needle and then get it in a
water bottle and you don't know but this
is like a carbonated can
once you puncture it they're going to
know that it's been tapered because it
won't get that nice crisp
fresh uh fresca fresh carbonation pop
and sizzle that it would get otherwise
yeah
i don't know what's going on it's
freaking me out it also could just be
the
um the white nikes of the heavens gate
cult
right right yeah every cult needs their
johnstown kool-aid yeah or uh playing
volleyball for the nexium cult if you're
watching the vow
yeah oh i love that series it's like my
new weekly television i'm like yes
we get some uh lovecraft country and
we'll get some nice lava
some some fake scary some real scary
just mixing it up yeah
which one's scarier this week well let
us know what you think is going on with
the prescott i'm sure we'll find out by
the end of this season but let's move on
to
our kill counts this week okay well this
was a big uptick eric
for kill counts it's been kind of a slow
couple episodes lots of action but not a
lot of death but boy
it came in spades this week so um a lot
of violence obviously taking place at
the sage grove center
um especially after that lockdown
happened and now
we we tried to count we were looking at
the little um
security camera footage and whatever and
a lot of the violence
you know there's tons of people dying
but it's off screen we hear the screams
we don't know who's dying
who's killing them what's confirmed so
we the kill count is only going to
reflect
confirmed deaths this week okay
okay also who knows when um a homelander
blows up his trailer
you know there had to be a poor teamster
standing outside just one pa
yeah i mean we've been
we've been just loitering on sets before
you just kind of lean up against a wall
and then it blows up and you're dead so
yeah yeah his electrical malfunction god
so uh speaking of homelander he comes in
with one confirmed kill
this week of course because he is the
one that squishes the head
of the robber in the opening sequence uh
before making love to storm front friend
she also had a confirmed kill he shoots
a security guard at the sage grove yeah
though i
i will say like when you see the the
bullet holes
are like black and i don't know if
that's just because there's not enough
time for the blood to come out
made me think the guy might have been
wearing a bulletproof vest and the gun
just kind of knocked him out but
let's say he killed him they were in
that room for a while i feel like he
would be able to be like
he would have woken up yeah billy
butcher of course kills the
emp uh soup who escapes the facility and
and harms
huey starlight kills the motorist who
pulled out the gun
uh love that character actor by the way
enjoyed his work on
monk and other other shows our friend
love sausage the wild wang
we saw him strangle and orderly with uh
his member lamplighter he killed
the telekinetic tim that guy yeah the
first sequence right who just wanted to
talk to his sister roasted him boy
that's all it takes to
get killed at sage grove just wanting to
talk to your family so dark
i guess he also mentioned uh we know
that he he killed
mallory's family in the past we're not
counting that in the total this time
because
yeah that didn't happen during the
episode we didn't see it on screen
kamiko
uh has two kills she kind of stomps the
face of the acid spewing
soup and then she also punched love
sausage and death
which by the way if your whole power is
that you spew acid
how messed up that you yourself are not
acid proof
yeah it just becomes uh acidic the
moment it
hits oxygen or something yeah i'm trying
to figure out the physics so i will say
there are some parallels to that in the
human body right like our stomachs are
relatively acid proof
but if our stomach acid even comes up
into our throat it does lots of damage
because our throat
interesting is not that's that's what um
uh heartburn
essentially is or acid reflux is that
part of our body is not nearly as acid
proof
as our stomach so and they have to tell
um like pregnant women who vomit
often uh not to brush their teeth right
after they vomit they have to like
switch it out with water because the
stomach acid can eat away at their teeth
enamel oh fascinating
see the boy's the most grounded show on
tv
cindy our new our our favorite uh
stranger things knock off
uh definitely uh doing some 11 cosplay
um she has somewhere between three and
four kills you see
her kill explode kind of three sage
grove
orderlies and it seemed like one of the
people that explode onto a window we
didn't see cindy do it but we could
probably assume
it was her though she is very nice to
the motorist who picks her up
hitchhiking
which who's picking up okay you know you
live in a neighborhood
with some kind of mental facility you
see somebody walking down the road
barefoot
i'll pick them up sure well look at that
guy in the michael myers mask
and then we did see on the security
footage the one like kind of confirmed
death there was some kind of one of the
the soup patients
has some kind of force field power a
lamp lighter-esque
kind of power and we see him roast kind
of two
orderlies or security guards and then a
stormfront
um definitely led this week as she's
been probably leading for the season
overall
six kills she said that she killed six
people
in the cleanup of the breakout at sage
grove i just killed
six subjects out there like a [ __ ]
teddy bear picnic
i don't know what that means but it's
great and of course she contributed to
the killing of uh
over six million jews so yep so there
you go yeah
yeah ultimately no matter what
stormfront killed the most people yeah
a lot of blood on her hands a fat sand
episode i can't wait to see where it
goes next week
zach it's been a pleasure uh talking to
you
uh we gotta go run some lines with black
noir but that is our show
um and uh and again tommy and marina
will be back
uh next week and and future other things
on the new rockstars channel they're
good friends just because you don't see
them here
it's like playing peek-a-boo with the
folks sometimes if they aren't in this
episode
it means philip is dead and in my trunk
they all still work here it's just
people are doing other stuff and only
zach and i have the free time to be able
to hop on camera
this week okay but tune in every week
for a reaction the latest boys episode
here on the boys underground and be sure
to subscribe to boys underground
on apple podcast spotify wherever you
get your podcasts
and leave us a nice rating and review it
really helps us uh
if we could trend this it'd be amazing
it would help us do more after shows in
the future for things like
the mandalorian for wanda vision we
really love doing these immediate after
shows in addition to like easter egg
breakdown so
uh yeah we love being able to do new
formats helping uh boys underground blow
up is a way you can help us do more
things like that reminder to join our
official discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstars
discord is where we're going to be
fielding questions that uh we'll answer
on the show
if we don't have time to discuss stuff
on the show we'll be talking about it on
discord and we have uh some big fans of
the boys who we love checking in with
every week
so you can become one of them by joining
us there uh follow me at eavos follow
zach at z huddleston
follow new rockstars on social subscribe
here on youtube to get too much
information on all the stuff you care
about
including the disgusting kills from
people who are supposed to be good guys
but are really just bad boys
bad boys see you next time thanks zack
[Music]
thanks